sie sagten kinder erlebten den
missbrauch als eine art normalität
wann haben sie eigentlich gemerkt
gespürt gefühlt dass das alles andere
als völlig normal ist was ihnen da
passiert also das ist wirklich sexueller
missbrauch war das ging mir erst auf als
sie schon erwachsen war
denn kinder sind ja zu 100 prozent auf
uns angewiesen und was wir ihnen als
normalität vor leben ist deren
normalität ich möchte da ein ganz
praktisches beispiel nennen meine
jüngste tochter ist zwei jahre alt
wenn ich die windeln in die hand nehme
dann weiß sie jetzt mit windeln
gewechselt und dann legt sie sich
automatisch hin
sie lässt sich ausziehen sie klappt
automatisch die beine auseinander und
selbst wenn sie wohnt ist und es
unangenehm ist nur ein bisschen weh tut
sie vertraut mir und sie lässt mich
fertig machen und genau so funktioniert
missbrauch ganz perfide ganz normal
eingebaut in den ganz normalen alltag
wir reden frau gefahr über die opfer in
allererster linie organisationen wie die
von frau von weiler helfen natürlich die
entscheidende frage ist warum eigentlich
so wenig staatliche hilfe rechtzeitig
genug kommt unbürokratisch ist diese
betroffenen von den schildern die
meisten betroffenen als an der
unheimlich lange braucht um überhaupt zu
reagieren um die gelder zur verfügung zu
stellen um die therapien zu ermöglichen
warum ist das so schwer naja also
zunächst mal also einen guten abend
sowieso und entschuldigung wer sich
etwas verspätet da war
wir haben seit einiger zeit wirklich
viel investiert um die strukturen zu
verbessern der unabhängige beauftragte
für sexuellen kindesmissbrauch oder für
fragen sexuellen kindesmissbrauchs ist
von mir in meiner amtszeit entfristet
wollen wir haben ihn mit seinem ganzen
team mit dem betroffenen rat auf dauer
gestellt das heißt er ruhig noch
dauerhaft arbeiten und dem ganzen team
mit mir zusammen wir uns heute darauf
verständigt dass wir auch zusätzlich zu
dem was wir ohnehin schon mal wir haben
letztes jahr einen nationalen rat gegen
sexuelle gewalt an kindern und
jugendlichen einberufen dass wir eine
aufklärungs und
sensibilisierungskampagne starten werden
die noch mal auch ganz auf das was sie
eben sagten angeht nämlich die frage wie
können wir es schaffen dass menschen
wirklich gewahr sind woran erkenne ich
dass eigentlich das ist ein ganz
entscheidender punkt wenn wir immer
darüber reden wie kann das eigentlich
passieren dann müssen wir auch darüber
reden wie konnte es sein dass niemand
das bemerkt hat klar und das dazu gehört
mut und dazu gehört dass wir das zum
thema machen und das machen wir seit
einiger zeit sehr sehr stark und das ist
eine aufgabe die auch immer während
andauert und da müssen wir investieren
und ich hab mir das fest vorgenommen das
zu tun und dass man hier ist gestartet
wenigstens verbal von heute da soll auch
noch mal einer aus ich habe mal das ist
bei weitem nicht alles wir haben den
betroffenen radio wir regelmäßig mit
betroffenen aussprechen wir haben
letztes jahr den nationalen rat ins
leben gerufen wir wollen auch
gesetzliche änderungen wir sind gerade
dabei unser kinder und jugendhilfe recht
auch zu modernisieren es wird
kinderschutz ist es fertig das gesetz
kommt demnächst auch ins kabinett um den
kinderschutz zu verstärken ich hoffe es
ist nicht fertig sondern ich hoffe der
austausch der kinderärzte kommt noch ein
ist erstaunlich dass sie das schon
wissen was da alles drücken wir haben es
gerade in die frühpension und angegeben
sie dass wir wollen das setze ich mich
so eine tolle botschaft verständlich ist
die frage der kinderärzte und die frage
wie das nämlich künftig passieren kann
das bundeskinderschutzgesetz könne die
kinderärzte schon melden da ist die
schweigepflicht ernst entbunden aber die
frage ist was kriegen denn die kinder
erst eigentlich zurück wenn sie ans
jugendamt melden das ist im moment nicht
geregelt und das muss geregelt werden
dass da auch eine rückkopplung passiert
dass eine enge zusammenarbeit mit den
streifen mit lungs behörden erfolgt und
auch natürlich mit der kinder- und
jugendhilfe halten jetzt haben sie den
betroffenen rat reden wir gleich noch
drüber sondern dass die täter wir sind
dann wieder bei den tätern natürlich
auch ärzte hopping betreiben und
umziehen um eben genau zu vermeiden dass
der eine kinderarzt genau das gleiche
was der andere auch schon wusste
brauchen sie sind in diesen betroffenen
rat den frau gerade angesprochen hat
wird denn da tatsächlich etwas getan
auch im sinne der opfer hat ihnen diese
forschung geholfen
der fonds ist eine extra geschichte ja
selber vor zwei jahren den antrag
gestellt und die hälfte wurde bewilligt
die andere hälfte noch nicht und dann
das das bewilligt wurde da hat dann auch
die auszahlung guten jahr gedauert also
das läuft alles nicht so wie es soll
aber trotzdem im großen und ganzen geht
es voran
das thema kommt immer mehr in die
politik und wir sitzen ja auch oft
zusammen mit vertretern aus dem
jugendschutz und da sitzen leute die
wissen ok in unseren behörden läuft sehr
viel schief wie können wir das denn
ändern
meine größte sorge ist einfach die
gesellschaft dass da eben immer noch
dieses wegschauen so ein großes thema
ist wir hatten das thema beim grillen
mit nachbarn und dann sagte der eine
junge vater ein ernstes bei uns auf dem
dorf gibt es sowas nicht
und das hört man halt immer wieder und
da muss noch was aufbrechen
wir haben sie frau gefahr zitiert damit
und wir kommen zur gesellschaft das in
jeder klasse ein bis zwei kindersitzen
die missbrauchsopfer sind warum fällt
das eigentlich lehrern und erziehern so
selten auf na ja auch da braucht es
sensibilität und vielfach ist dass er
eben kein thema in schulen und das ist
eine frage die wir beantworten müssen
wie wird das zum thema wie werden kinder
stark gemacht wir haben eine initiative
trau dich wo wir mit theaterpädagogik
arbeiten um das zu unterstützen
aber es muss eigentlich in jeder schule
in jeder klasse ein thema sein auch
frühzeitig darüber gesprochen werden
damit kinder auch selbst wo es genug
sind und vor allen dingen wissen wo sie
sich hilfe holen können das ist ja im
moment die problematik wir wollen auch
mit dem neuen kinder- und jugendhilfe
recht einen eigenen beratungs anspruch
denn jedes kind haben soll etablieren wo
es also nicht die eltern fragen muss
kann ich mir bereiten sondern wo das
kind unabhängig vom wissen der eltern
das tun kann
das sind alles so wichtige punkte aber
die müssen die kinder wissen und die
erzieherinnen und erzieher lehrer und
lehrer müssen das auch wissen und wenn
sie es nicht tun dann können sie auch
nicht sensibel reagieren und wir
brauchen alle mehr aufmerksamkeit und
mehr 88 wohl nochmal frage nach erfurt
so ein mist dachte oder
missbrauchsverdacht ist natürlich auf
der anderen seite auch extrem
schwerwiegend und manchmal wird er auch
benutzt oder wird böswillig gestreut
sind deshalb auch menschen so vorsichtig
mit einem solchen verdacht zu den
behörden zu gehen ganz sicher wird das
einer der fälle sein dass menschen sagen
ich will ja kein reduzieren
und es gibt ja auch schon klima in der
gesellschaft dass man sowas kaum gibt
ich fand den hinweis richtig bei uns im
dorf gibt so was nicht
ich glaube dass das hauptproblem ist wir
haben das problem ein völlig ernst
genommen negiert verdrängt nicht
wahrhaben wollen dazu kommt dann die
sorge man will kein anschwärzen
im ergebnis dass auf jeden fall
weggeguckt worden und das ist das
hauptproblem
und ich finde was die aufgabe ist das
von allen beteiligten dafür zu sorgen
dass das mitten in die gesellschaft
gerückt wird mittendrin und das keiner
diesem thema entkommt sondern sich dem
stellen muss und dann auch position
beziehen muss jeder hat seine stelle
übrigens also eine allein oder eine
institution alleine wird es nicht machen
zu glauben die polizei würde das allein
errichten das ja abenteuerlich aber wenn
jeder seinen job macht und wir alle die
kräfte intensiver forcieren
da bin ich ganz sicher wird das wirkung
harmonie ich kann ihn sein seitdem wir
da gas geben um ein bild zu sagen merke
ich dass das thema eine höhere relevanz
hat es hat eine wirkung die leute haben
zwar erst über mich gemeckert und haben
wir für alles verantwortlich war da
immer diese neuen fälle aufgedeckt
werden aber die wahrheit ist jeder neue
fall zeigt die dramatik eine neue fall
führt uns natürlich auch dazu das war
kinder rausholen
also möglich die härteren strafen sind
gegen den missbrauch sind noch zu milde
die forderung nach härteren strafen
die ist natürlich sofort im raum gewesen
es muss möglich sein für täter und
mittäter sexuellen missbrauchs
drastische strafen zu ermöglichen
der pauschale ruf nach einer abstrakten
strafrechtsverschärfungen bei
kinderpornographie wie er von frau kramp
karrenbauer kommt führt nicht weiter
koalitionskrach vor zehn tagen um die
richtige strategie gegen
kindesmissbrauch
die union ist empört wir können noch
nichts dazu und das wäre das ein
ladendiebstahl was da an missbrauch
passiert ist wie wort und da erwarte ich
dass es ab wien verbrechen bestraft wird
und auch in der spd absetzbewegungen von
der justizministerin
es kann nicht sein dass es immer wieder
täter gibt die bereits wegen
kindesmissbrauchs vorbestraft sind und
dann erneut ein kind opfer wird künftig
muss es weniger bewährungsstrafen und
mehr sicherheit vor wiederholungstätern
geben
nun schwenkt die justizministerin um aus
dem vergehen soll auch juristisch ein
verbrechen werden
patrick strafen waren also immer wieder
und sind immer wieder eine populäre
forderung sind sie auch eine
populistische heraus glaube ich
überhaupt nicht wissen sie ich glaube
auch nicht dass die härte strafe das
problem löst haben ja nie behauptet aber
sorgt dafür dass das gesellschaftliche
signal heißt das ist nicht irgendwas ist
es etwas ganz schlimmes und da müssen an
manchen stellen eben auch klare signale
gesetzt werden darum ging es und wir
haben über ein jahr gebraucht vor einem
jahr haben wir in ihrem car angefangen
mit dieser debatte endlich
ministerkonferenz und jetzt endlich
passiert was und ich sage ihnen das ist
auch nur ein teil strafe noch mal traf
allein ist es nicht aber das signal wir
nehmen das nicht mehr auf die leichte
schulter
das ist zentral dass uns die taschen der
das auch noch mal franziska giffey
die meisten dieser vergehen waren eben
nicht als verbrechen klassifiziert
sondern in anführungsstrichen juristisch
nur als vergehen gab es in ihren augen
dafür den gute gründe oder hat die
justizministerin frau lambrecht das
einfach zu lange unbearbeitet gelassen
ich glaube dass es ein ganz starkes
empfinden in der bevölkerung gibt dass
das verbrechen sind und die frage ist ja
dann immer was wird im juristischen
sinne als verbrechen definiert und was
empfinden wir auch so und ich finde es
aber aus sicht der kinder ministerin und
familienminister ganz wichtig dass wir
hier wirklich alles was juristisch was
in unserem rechtssystem geht an
strafverschärfung augusta waffen
unmöglich machen
mir ist ja insofern dass auch immer ein
bisschen problematisch wir haben 15.000
bekannte opfer im jahr die in der
polizeistatistik in der
kriminalstatistik auftaucht
wir hatten 2008 10 847 verurteilung aber
wenn man sich mal anschaut wie die aus
diese verurteilung dann war das höchste
zwischen fünf und zehn jahren und das
waren 8 fälle und die anderen sind mit
weniger rausgegangen und das ist
eigentlich unsere problematik wir haben
schon jetzt einen strafraum der 15 jahre
plus sicherungsverwahrung vorsieht aber
es wird eben nicht ausgeschöpft und
damit verbunden muss doch viel eher auch
sein dass wir eine kindgerechte justiz
brauchen wie eben die strafverfahren so
ausübt dass eben die kinder auch mit
beteiligt werden dass sie angehört
werden dass sie einen verfahrensbeistand
bekommt und dass kinder auch so befragt
werden das kind gerichtet wir haben doch
oft gar keinen anderen beweis als die
zeugenaussage eines kindes mehr gibt es
ja häufig nicht und wenn kinder eben
nicht ordentlich befragt werden dann
manchmal die technik im gericht versagt
nach dem motto oh da das müssen wir
jetzt nochmal aufzeichnen was soll denn
da rauskommt schlechte verfahren sind
täterschutz an der stelle und gute
verfahren gute kinderschutz verfahren
gute verfahren können täter überführen
können zu höheren strafen führen haben
die nochmals sowie den klimaschutz
gesprochen und für die vertretung der
kinder
das ist extrem wichtig aber dadurch
einfach eine kinderrechte im grundgesetz
so dass und noch mal und jetzt hat ja
aber sogar ihre amtsvorgängerin frau
schwesig jetzt ministerpräsident in
mecklenburg vorpommern eine
bundesratsinitiative anstrengen wollen
eben weil sie auch das gefühl hatte dass
da zu wenig passiert ist damit diese
bundesratsinitiative per du denken also
wir haben ja heute auch eine aktuelle
stunde im bundestag dazu gehabt
überfordert und christine lambrecht hat
sich ja ganz klar geäußert sie hat das
in ihrem haus geprüft welche
möglichkeiten es gibt es soll vor der
sommerpause noch ein verabschiedete
gesetzentwurf geben der auch eingebracht
wird und dann ist das etwas wo es ist
ein klares bekenntnis gibt an dieser
stelle mehr zu tun
auch in puncto kinderpornografie wir
begrüßen das absolut aus sicht des
familienministeriums aus sicht der
betroffenen mit denen wir ganz oft auch
ich persönlich sehr oft in kontakt bin
das ist der richtige weg und da müssen
wir jetzt auch weiter machen und da
musst du frau lamprecht offensichtlich
nur noch hier und da ein bisschen
deutlicher zu hören frau hat jetzt
können härtere strafen natürlich nicht
die alleinige antwort sein
aber sind sie dennoch notwendig
versorgen sie sind definitiv notwendig
denn die betroffenen leiden ja nicht nur
während der taten das sind ja oft jahre
sondern die mit
sich ja auch wie frau von weiter schon
gesagt hat oft ihr ganzes leben lang mit
den folgen rumschlagen und dann kann es
nicht sein dass da nur bewährungsstrafen
dabei rauskommen und des rudels
schneider im gros der fälle fragen wir
noch mal nach hamburg
herr briten würden sie sagen dass diese
höheren strafen den täter abschrecken
können von ihrem tun
es gibt sicherlich eine abschreckung
durch höhere strafen das ist sicherlich
ein anteil davon viel wichtiger
erscheint mir im moment aber und das ist
in der diskussion bisher noch nicht zu
wort gekommen dass wir sehr sehr lange
verfahrensdauern haben oder eine sehr
lange dauer haben es überhaupt
irgendetwas passiert und das sind phasen
in denen die betroffenen kinder unter
umständen nicht ausreichend geschützt
werden weil es noch kontakte gibt
wir haben aber auch den abschreckungs
charakter den eine strafe hat natürlich
wenn es eine zeitliche verzögerung von
vielleicht bis zu zwei jahren gibt nicht
in der art und weise wie wir es
eigentlich haben müssten
das ist ein ressourcen und
kapazitätsproblem und dieses problem
müssen wir aus meiner auffassung ganz
sicher auch angehen nicht das eine gegen
das andere ausspielen die kinderrechte
sind da ganz im vordergrund aber dieses
kapazitätsproblem und diese zeitlichen
abläufe wirklich zu verändern das
scheint mir im moment noch viel
vorrangiger sehen denn auch die frage an
den fachmann sehen die täter denn
wenigstens später ihr unrecht ein fühlen
sie sich wenigstens später schuldig bei
komplexen themen ist es immer so dass
man nicht das einfach mit ja oder nein
beantworten kann wir haben zum glück
muss man sagen auch täter die hinterher
reue empfinden reihe erleben
schuldgefühle haben das sind natürlich
auch diejenigen die wir dann unter
umständen auch wirklich gut darin
unterstützen können das nicht wieder
etwas passiert wir haben es aber auch
mit menschen zu tun